too many muscles can make for a sticky
situation
muscles are marine bio Fowler's like
barnacles and seaweed
it'll take any opportunity to attach
themselves to an object they can clog
pipes destroy scientific equipment and
damage dams and boats researchers have
spent decades trying to prevent muscles
from attaching to everything they
encountered now they've developed the
polymer lubricant that prevents the
muscles for attaching to underwater
surfaces the key to the muscle
stickiness is Bissell effects a sticky
fiber the animal secretes as soon as it
detects a solid structure the new
lubricant repels organic matter so the
scientists hypothesize that will prevent
the muscle from noticing the surface
beneath an initiating attachment in
testing that Asian green muscle cooked
it's the key appendage out of the
surface but it couldn't grab hold the
coating worked the coating also worked
in the field after eight weeks and
submersion plates coated with a polymer
only averaged four muscles per square
centimeter the control averaged 118
they're still testing to be done before
this anti muscle material will reach the
market but for scientists and sailors
alike it could be a license
[Music]